a 42 here have you ever called a
customer support line and heard the
phrase this call may be recorded for
training and Quality Assurance purposes
well the truth is your recorded phone
call will most likely never be used for
training an extremely small number of
calls actually are so why are all these
companies recording millions of phone
calls on a daily basis data all these
recorded phone calls are automatically
sent to companies that develop
algorithms as soon as you hang up the
phone your conversation is being
analyzed by computer code one such
companies chicago-based mata site mata
site and over such companies have
developed intelligent machine learning
algorithms that analyze billions of
phone conversations every single day
sent to them directly by large companies
Mata sites largest client sends them
over 250 million recorded phone calls
every day their computers examine what
you say how you say it the words you
choose and the tone that you use to
determine your personality and put you
into a group of other people with
similar personalities you may for
example respond well to hard facts and
figures or you may better respond to
personal sentiments and compliments you
may be short and aggressive with your
tone or you may be patient you may be
shy sarcastic blunt outgoing within
minutes after you first call a call
center mata sites algorithm has attached
a personality label to your phone number
then the next time you call lat or any
other company that buys mata site
services you are automatically routed to
a customer service agent that has a
similar personality to yours you are
routed to a person that can better tap
into your psyche to more efficiently
sell you products or to solve your
problem quicker the result is shorter
more pleasant phone calls for every
involved unhappier clients and of course
boosted sales for the company this has
happened to you hundreds of times over
hundreds of phone calls without you ever
even realizing it so how do you feel
about this should you feel like your
trust has been betrayed your privacy
invaded well you could do but in reality
these are what's known as blackbox
algorithms no real humans are listening
to your phone call and the data that
these algorithms extract and use from
millions of aggregated phone
conversations isn't even visible to the
engineers who create the algorithms it's
all just maths your words are first
converted into numbers and then
transmogrification millions of times by
computer software the end result is so
obfuscated and so vastly complex that
all the people behind the scenes
actually see is a black box of billions
of numbers that takes phone calls as an
input and spits out a personality label
as an output nobody is listening in to
you complain about that pair of pajamas
you just purchased with a tear in the
crotch because no one cares and in the
end thanks to these algorithms you will
be put through to someone who
assimilates really well with yourself
and you'll probably hang up the phone
having had a shorter happier and more
resolute full conversation algorithms
are not a new thing we have been living
by algorithms and using them to enhance
our lives for literally thousands of
years a simple recipe is an algorithm
you take an input that is ingredients
follow a set of predefined instructions
and if you're good enough at cooking you
get an output a tasty meal the ancient
Greeks Babylonians and ancient Egyptians
all developed their own mathematical
algorithms to accomplish a variety of
basic tasks and make life simpler but
today
algorithms define your life like never
before in
your whole life everything and everyone
in it has pretty much already been
decided by an algorithm without you even
realizing it whether you can get a
credit card a loan or a mortgage to buy
your dream home has been decided by an
algorithm which school you go to or your
children go to your exam scores your
university degree are all determined by
algorithms when you sit down to watch a
film on Netflix or Amazon
statistics show that you're most likely
to watch a film that has been
recommended to you by an algorithm but
it gets a lot more personal than that
since 2010 online dating has been the
most popular way for new couples to get
together and today the majority of new
couples meet online now if you're the
type of person who believes in fate and
a one true love then maths would like to
have a word with you if you met your
partner online a series of steps had to
happen to lead up to that point both of
you in your partner had to first
discover and sign up to said dating
website or app that most likely happened
because you both saw an ad or search
listing for said dating service an
algorithm whether it was Google's or a
nova decided that you based on your
search and web browsing history and
whether these algorithms have
categorized you as an elite single a
sugar daddy a lonely over 50 or more of
a plentyoffish type of person then you
will see an ad or search result for the
appropriate dating website at that point
in time once you've signed up to the
dating website you will be asked to fill
out your profile and answer a series of
never-ending questions about your
personality and whether you enjoy long
walks on the beach which is a really
strange question because the vast
majority people don't live near a beach
based on your answers and the words you
put on your profile an algorithm will
then decide which matches should be
shown to you you may then take it upon
yourself to flirt with one of said
matches and become romantically
entangled
so then maths not fate has narrowed down
a small handful of people from your area
out of a few thousand possibilities so
maths has decided who you might spend
the rest of your life with and the
children that you may have so if you
think about it today computers are
breeding humans now that's trippy
you know what else is trippy skill
shares online learning community with
thousands of classes in design business
technology and so much more
Premium Membership gives you a limited
access to high-quality classes on must
know topics so you can improve your
skills unlock new opportunities and do
the work you love if like me you find
the power of algorithms and artificial
intelligence fascinating then you should
definitely watch the skill share course
deep learning and neural networks with
Python it's a must watch if you want to
create your own powerful machine
learning algorithms that can even rival
loads of the big tech companies don't
know how to program with Python well
there are loads of great courses on
skill sure to teach you have to be a
skilled coder in just a few days
Skillshare is also so much more
affordable than most learning platforms
out there an annual subscription is less
than ten dollars a month and I don't
need no algorithm to tell me that that's
good value and since Skillshare is
sponsoring this video the first 1,000
people to use the promo link in the
description will get their first two
months for just 99 cents algorithms have
already been running the world's
financial systems for over five years
now not only do algorithmic systems that
use big data to side automatically
whether you should be accepted for a
credit card a loan or a mortgage but the
world's biggest markets the financial
markets are today traded almost entirely
autonomously by computers traders used
to leverage algorithms as a sort of
guidance but the final decision on
whether to buy or sell stocks bonds
options or futures would be made by a
human an experienced trader but over the
past five years a huge shift has
occurred due to rapid advancements in
computer processing power and speed
today around 80 percent of financial
trades are made by black box algorithms
thousands of times every second in 2006
only 30% of trades were made
algorithmically but the scary part is
humans are not making these trades worth
millions of pounds the City of London
and Wall Street are no longer employing
experienced traders they're employing
mathematicians and physicists to create
algorithms that will make trades
automatically every millisecond with no
human import or decision process
whatsoever trading pits and floors have
been emptied of people and replaced with
servers generally these lightning-fast
algorithms make money or move vast sums
of money around in the most cost
efficient way but we don't know how they
work we just rely on the fact that over
a period of time they're more accurate
faster and make far less mistakes than
humans that's great but the cost of all
this is that when an algorithm does go
wrong when it does make a mistake
not only can it be devastating but we
have no way of knowing why or how it
happened because they are black boxes we
cannot look inside them and so happened
in the flash crash of 2010 on May the
6th 2010 always running smoothly when
suddenly without warning at 2:45 p.m.
all of the world's largest financial
markets such as the S&P 500 and the Dow
Jones collapsed within seconds a drop
larger than that of the infamous Black
Monday and The Wall Street Crash of 1929
within a minute over a trillion dollars
was wiped from the US and world
economies
a trillion dollars of money vanished in
less than the time it takes to make a
cup of tea now when it comes to
predicting future trends and events
algorithms today are far more accurate
than humans in recent years several
mathematicians have created algorithms
for predicting which films will win
Oscars each year just based on their
plot and the actors involved these
algorithms have been able to predict
with between 85 to 100 percent accuracy
the winners of all major categories at
the past two Academy Awards if humans
were to make the same predictions their
guesses would be no better than rolling
a dice london-based company epic objects
has made these predictive algorithms
commercial and uses them to consult
large film studios on what will make
them the most money for their future
film releases epic objects machine
learning algorithms can accurately
predict which film scripts will make
that studio money and which will be a
flop before they're even made but
interestingly they have also computed
which film stars are worth hiring this
may come as a surprise but one of their
algorithms computed that there are only
three actors in existence that adds
value to a film that is to say their
name appearing on the movie poster and
credits will increase the box office
numbers every other actor in the world
makes no difference whatsoever no matter
how much of a household name they may be
according to the algorithm the only free
actors in the world that can make a film
more money a Brad Pitt Johnny Depp and
strangely Will Smith the algorithm also
worked out that there is one actress who
is a huge household name but actually
causes every film she appears it to make
less money for obvious reasons the
company refused to say who she is but
when algorithms start to be utilized for
more serious issues
things start to get really controversial
one public sector that has dived
headfirst onto the algorithmic hype
train is the police in most major
countries police forces are now trying
out sci-fi like algorithms that can do
crazy stuff such as predict when and
where a crime is likely to happen before
it does and the reason police forces are
getting so hyped up about these minority
report style algorithms is that they
work really well using thousands of data
points such as the current weather
conditions traffic statistics about
neighborhoods such as average income
social backgrounds and education these
algorithms in use by the police today
can predict with uncanny precision
dynamically where a crime might happen
to the minute police use these systems
to more effectively allocates their
officers to specific areas of a city but
this isn't new so-called predictive
policing has been used for the past few
years now and it's becoming more and
more common all the time in fact I
talked about it in more depth in a video
last year but something is new something
even more controversial new algorithms
have been recently developed that can
calculate any civilians threat score
what is a threat score you say well
billions of data points are taken into
account within seconds obviously this
includes a person's arrest records but
worryingly it goes a lot more personal
limit the algorithm locks as a person's
property records education history
commercial databases from companies that
person has used or associated with and
most personally of all their social
media network who they're friends with
and every single one of their tweets
posts images and videos and even their
web searches it uses all this
information to algorithmically calculate
a threat
score about that person similar to a
credit score the higher the fret score
the more of a potential risk that
individual could be to the police or of
a civilians so in practice when a call
comes to an officer they can tap in that
person's name into their in-car computer
and the system will instantaneously
reveal that suspects threat score before
they even arrive on see if they have a
high fret score the suspect will be
treated far more cautiously the tasers
and guns will be at the ready as that
person's fret score indicates they are
more likely to be carrying a weapon and
hence more likely to use it against
others when the algorithm gets it right
that is currently being trialed by many
police forces in the US this kind of
social rating system opens up a whole
kind of controversial worm's how do you
feel like you might be held at gunpoint
and potentially fired at after a minor
fistfight
just because you tweeted five years ago
that he fought Hitler had a good
dressen's for an evil dictator causing
your fret score to skyrocket because of
course that must indicate you're some
kind of neo-nazi whereas someone who has
a clean social history might be treated
more compassionately and calmly arrested
with no guns involved and this is
essentially the glaring issue with
algorithms when they are used for
life-or-death situations there is no
doubt that algorithms are frightening ly
accurate in our modern age of big data
but what if that tweets you made about
Hitler's dress sense was meant
ironically sarcastically or satirically
and has no real reflection on your
general character and empathy towards
other humans this is what separates
algorithms from humans computers are not
yet able to tell the difference between
genuine intention and sarcasm or humor
and they don't yet fully understand and
appreciate the subtleties of human
conversation and interaction algorithms
are even being used today by courtrooms
to mathematically
Herman a convicted prisoners punishment
how much jail time they will serve and
where they will serve it using similar
data points as to fret score algorithm
is this right one has to ask if a
computer is more fair at said sentencing
than a human would beep and this is just
a tip of the mathematical iceberg when
it comes to punishment and law
enforcement it's no secret that certain
countries have long been collecting vast
amounts of data about their citizens
phone calls emails photos videos and
more thanks to whistleblowers like
Snowden but it's how they have been
using said data in combination with
algorithms that's really powerful the
vast amounts of data that the NSA GCHQ
and other agencies vacuums up on its
citizens such as phone records mobile
GPS locations online searches Facebook
activity and so much more is sifted
through organized and tagged by an
algorithm so that intelligence service
operatives can just run a simple text
search on anybody and see exactly where
they have been who they have spoken to
and because of the predictive power of
algorithms and mass data their systems
can even predict what we might be
planning to do in the future
launching a terrorist attack for example
if you have say liked a certain page on
Facebook and recently shopped at a
certain hardware store and you happen to
be friends with someone from a
particular country then the automated
algorithms that use at the NSA and other
agencies may have put you on a watch
list even if you don't actually have any
negative intentions my god for all the
weird stuff I've searched over the years
making these videos I would be surprised
if I wasn't on every watch list going a
study at Cambridge University found that
algorithms developed by intelligence
services could build an exact character
and personality description of anyone
including their sexuality political
views and ideologies based
on the Facebook pages that they have
liked could a human do this given the
same information no humans don't have
access to billions of data points to
compare that information against and
identify these subtle trends that the
algorithms pick up on and even if we did
we are computationally unable to process
such vast amounts of data but whether
this dragnet 1984 style mass
surveillance is a good or a bad thing is
a highly philosophical question there
were four awful terrorist attacks in the
UK in 2017 but according to mi5 there
were also nine over planned terrorist
attacks that were prevented and it's
very highly likely that these
algorithmically driven mass surveillance
systems were at least partially
responsible for discovering and stopping
set attacks this can only be a good
thing right
lives have without a doubt being saved
without the cost of our freedom privacy
anonymity is to trade-off between a lack
of privacy and increased state security
worth it well that's not for me to
decide for you but it's a question we
all should consider the more we
integrate algorithms into our lives the
more our lives are enhanced in many ways
we have cheaper airline tickets because
the prices are more efficiently
calculated by algorithms we arguably
find better relationship matches today
thanks to our personalities being
evaluated
rather than whoever smiled at us across
the bar we get better shopping
recommendations than ever we visit
better and more interesting cafes and
restaurants thanks to recommendation
algorithms we go on better holidays but
the dark sides to integrating all these
mathematical systems into our lives is
that huge decisions that affect us in
irreparable ways such as mortgage
approvals prison sentences and
surveillance have lost their human touch
we are now only numbers waiting to be
crunched thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please click
here
for me on patreon and I'd like to thank
skill show once again for sponsoring
this video don't forget to click the
link in the description to take
advantage of this incredible offer
before you're too late